Aaron Rodgers taking to Instagram with a
Shawshank Redemption quote I have to
remind myself that some birds aren't
meant to be caged and when they fly away
a part of you that knows it was a sin to
lock them up does rejoice still the
place you live in is that much more drab
and empty that they're gone I guess I
just miss my friend
yeah hashtag friendship hashtag team
mates hashtag brothers hashtag Packers
who's left now this is the and here's
the thing you don't want to live forever
because all your loved ones and friends
will eventually die you don't want to be
a quarterback in the NFL for 20 years
because eventually all your friends are
gonna be gone yeah and you're gonna have
to make new friends you're gonna have
got a lot you're the old guy and you
don't know anybody in there and you got
a recent all that time you spent in that
one relationship all that time you
invested forget about that you got to
spend all this time with a new got it'll
drive you crazy if you let it
what does this mean for Aaron Rodgers
now that Randall Cobbs gone Jordy Nelson
last year Demonte Adams is the old man
in the locker room at the receiver
positions about two young guys and what
does that mean for Aaron Rodgers how
does he feel about this yeah well I mean
I don't think he's sitting at home going
man well look at me I got weapons galore
I think he's been saying that for the
last few years really honestly I mean
hey Jordy Nelson's still a solid player
but he's not special at this point in
his career I mean this I think we're
improving at Randall Cobb has not really
been special for a few years it's
probably been three years since he has
this is part of what I've been arguing
with Aaron Rodgers this is why I love
his greatness because you know there's
guys like this that we never hear of
every year who contribute at the wide
receiver position Valdes scantling it
couldn t me a saint Brown you know you
get to those type of guys and you go who
the hell are they but they look they're
catching passes and they're not even
open but Rodgers threw a laser right in
there and got it to him so I think at
some point they've realized hey Rodgers
can make it happen no matter what we
don't have to spend money for huge
weapons at the wide receiver position
and I think they're trusting their
evaluations a little bit you know guys
like this the guys we put up on the the
st. Brown they got potential there's no
doubt about it Valdez scantling had some
good moments last year so I think
they're gonna go with some of these
young guys and hope they can continue to
get better and remember
was last year during training camp he
called out the young guys for not
properly running their routes and
understanding what they needed to do in
a inula Alison we got to remember him
he's back yeah he's back
but and they spent money this year in
free agency but it was primarily on the
defensive side of all they added
offensive lineman Billy Turner but no
money spent on skill position players no
no running backs no no receivers other
than bringing Allison bag no new tight
ends they brought back Mercedes Lewis
but you know Jared Cook was and
theoretically is still out there and
that was a guy that he stumped for him
why didn't we pay Jared Cook there are
the the Gramm contract that's what I
don't understand mean that's proving to
be a little bit of a mistake well that
was a year I think I think Jimmy Graham
got what he got because they screwed up
Jared cook yeah and that was the
reaction because instead of Jared cook
they saw Martellus Bennett that was a
disaster and the next year they said
let's pay Jimmy Graham and I'm surprised
they kept Jimmy Graham because he's been
a disappointment so far he's not the guy
that he used to be but cooks still very
good but it looks like the Saints are
gonna land him the Packers I guess could
still get involved late and try to get
him back yet back in Green Bay and I
just wonder where the Packers are right
now from the standpoint of how
deferential they even want to be to
Aaron Rodgers on one hand I look at the
hiring of Matt Lafleur and I think they
wanted a guy that's gonna work well with
Aaron Rodgers right and will maybe be
deferential to Rodgers because Rodgers
is the face of the franchise Rodgers had
the most important employee in the
organization 33 and a half million per
year in new money on his new contract
he's the guy who's gonna be there for
the next four or five years but then
you're not making personnel moves that
seem to be in any way designed to
placate him now the draft may be
different yeah they're gonna load up
running backs trapper could be a big
thing it could be one of their
first-round picks I can imagine going a
receiver there sitting in that position
do what you do have to yes right so
they're good they're good be in a spot
next year or this year in the draft
where yeah one of the real good
receivers in the draft is available
would not be shocked if they made that
move but you know hey they're there
they're trusting or what I think they're
doing is going okay we got Billy Turner
to improve the offensive line a bit a
little bit let's protect Lafleur's new
offense
Nate Hackett's gonna be involved who I
think a lot of okay and that
collaboration I think they think the
offense will be more creative and I
think that at the end of the day they're
realizing they have so
special talent at quarterback that he
can make it work with maybe you know
less than the the normal quarterback
could make work I guess is what I'm
trying to say there and and yeah I would
agree with that but I do wish they would
add one more playmaker
to you know the fold here just to take a
little pressure off them at times
because we've seen in the past and
recent history when the Packers have to
play good defenses with good corners
it's just it's every player's Oh Rodgers
has to make magic and that's where I
constantly get sick of defending him
because of that because then it doesn't
look pretty and people go all his
completion percentage is not that great
this game and I want to go well like we
all went back and watch the film I would
show you that here's the 45 times you
drop back to pass and here's only the
two times people were actually open so
that's what I always defend Aaron
Rodgers with I don't think that'll be
the case here because I think some of
these young guys are unknown but a
little more talented than the public
knows for a third-round pick and a fifth
round pick and 51 million or so over
three years should the Packers have made
I know Antonio Brown right I I mean I
would have loved to have seen that
certainly that or levy on bail I mean I
thought maybe they would get involved in
the levy on bail conversation to to a
degree I think Rodgers and Brown could
have coexisted I do
I think Rodgers has enough personality
and charisma about him and then I think
again and we're talking about Aaron
Rodgers I do yes I do I think he does
and I think that with the guy that
talent not mr. Rogers not mr. Rodgers
I'm talking about the Aaron Rodgers
who's one of the better interviews in
football always and gives you honest
answers and really answers things
honestly I'm so sick of hearing all his
leadership stuff and all that
hey the leadership you know we blame
Aaron Rodgers for leadership you know
with the Packers but then Mike Tomlin
gets blamed for it
with you know the Pittsburgh Steelers I
don't understand that no Mike McCarthy
was part of the issue there you know you
can't call plays on Sunday and not be in
the offensive meetings during the week
there's issues that will make the
quarterback roll his eyes during a game
when the coach who wasn't in the game
planning calls a play and you go oh
that's stupid we told it we talked all
week we wouldn't call this play in this
situation and now he's gonna call it and
then we're shocked that the guy rolled
his eyes so yeah I think there's just
more to it that's gone on in Green Bay
and I think Rodgers has been frustrated
at times because he has to do
much I just wonder what he could have
done what he should have done if that's
what was going on yeah do you just deal
with it your own way or do you find a
way to navigate the organizational chart
to go to somebody and say look we got a
problem here I don't want to be disloyal
to my code right but we got some issues
that we need to address let's have a
conversation about how engaged the coach
really is in game planning then on game
day what he tries to do we need to if we
want to be as good as we can be we need
to make some adjustments hi I make that
point because I can envision Peyton
Manning in that circumstance finding
away yeah to talk to whoever needs to be
talked to above Mike McCarthy to make
sure that the alarm is sounded because I
only got so many years left in my career
right and they're being waste and look
maybe it did maybe that's why Matloff or
maybe not so they went to the
restructuring of how they had the
pecking order in the organization and
then in which it led to the next year of
McCarthy being gone yeah I don't know
and it may very well be that the first
step was moving on from Ted Thompson
because it may very well be and this is
all speculation folks but it may very
well be that Aaron Rodgers tried to go
to a guy like Ted Thompson to better
manage and supervise Mike McCarthy and
Ted Thompson didn't want to have
anything to do it right exactly right
there's definitely that possibility so
you know what we don't know what went on
I just get sick of hearing Aaron Rodgers
leadership things I don't think it's
fair always is he perfect all the time
I'm shocked by your posture well I know
but also I would like to challenge so
you know somebody challenged me on what
he has done that shown lack of
leadership you know I don't understand
that I don't think he not based upon
because look as many former teammates
have complained about him right as
former teammates have complained about
Ben Roethlisberger and you acknowledge
there's something with Ben
Roethlisberger when it comes to the
personal connection yes to teammates I
think Rodgers has the same issue now I
don't think is he's a jerk right per se
but I don't think he connects the way
that he needs to him we talked earlier
in the show about how if you're gonna
get on these guys on the practice field
you need to have a beer with him you
need to hang out with them they need to
have your cell phone you need to have
that question and you need to be texting
gifts back and forth to each other and
having the kind of relationship we have
right you need to have that so you can
get through and past those moments where
you call a guy out to a reporter because
he screwed up during practice if you
don't have the personal relationship to
balance out how rocky things can get
professionally from time to time you're
gonna have that wall there's going to be
a barrier there that makes it harder to
lead yeah no III
mean you made a lot of good points and
you're exactly right I'm not saying he's
perfect but I don't think he's on Big
Ben's level either I don't think that's
the case
I agree with you that but I totally
espares when he retires and says like in
only names like five players he ever
played with in the history of the sport
after a 16 or 17 year career and Aaron
Rodgers is one of them where he said he
was one of the best teammates he ever
played with yeah cuz he left me alone
well that's the thing George Pepper's is
a different bird but they wanted to be
left alone in era Rogers left them oh
okay well the receivers that complain
about Aaron Rodgers until we know that
our guys that all like left town and
they probably feel like Aaron Rodgers
could have saved them from leaving town
because he had that kind of power within
the organization in general to where I
know I think we also have to look at the
situation of the guys who have come out
and said those things where I want to go
I think there's a little bit of a
personal aspect here as well that you're
just not happy that you know you were
there and you were doing pretty good and
they didn't keep you around and you had
to go play for the Minnesota Vikings
next or whoever it may be who you're
talking about Greg Julie yeah just some
of those the best pass-catching tight
end Aaron Rodgers has ever had juh
Michael Finley
juh Michael Finley never had Aaron
Rodgers phone number mmm okay according
to Michael Finn yeah okay is that it
first came up a few years ago that this
was the thing that started what was it
2016 of there abouts tyler done of
Bleacher yeah you may be familiar he's
great
Tyler's the manager but and he did a
great article that they called into
question how good of a leader is Aaron
Rodgers capable of being the leader the
Packers need and it wasn't long after
that the things started to kind of
crumble a little bit I felt like Rodgers
were taking some shots at Mike McCarthy
that's when Aaron Rodgers called me out
and said don't waste your time reading
that crap maybe one of the most astute
observations ever made but that's when
that all came up and Finley said in that
article I don't have his eye when I
weren't played there I didn't have his
phone number
ya know okay you know again I don't I
don't condone that yes but just because
he didn't have his phone number doesn't
mean he's that bad a bad leader either
you know okay I didn't have everybody on
the offense his phone number
you know Jer Michael Finley was a very
young player at the time sure Michael
Finley you know if we really want to get
it I don't think he was exactly perfect
at that point in his life
you may not somebody that you would want
on your phone well that's what I mean so
I'm not gonna go down that wormhole
there but I do think there was you know
if we really want to dive into he said
he said I could certainly throw out some
things about your michael finley where
you go okay well I'm not so sure I'd
want to have his no number either so yes
I mean again it's not always perfect I
understand that and when you are the
face of the franchise and an Aaron
Rodgers who is the man and I'm sure
everybody there treats him like the man
you know guys are gonna get jealous at
times and it's a little different yes
it's not New England and the power
structure that's there that's a special
place and that's been you know set up by
Bill Belichick in a culture that's been
set up by him from day one and that's
not in place and a lot of places in the
NFL all right good observations all
around and look I think Aaron Rodgers is
one of the best quarterbacks the NFL has
ever seen but I don't I still don't know
just like a Pittsburgh I don't know who
to blame for the fact that the Steelers
haven't been back to the Superbowl since
the 2010 season I don't know who to
blame in great man I mean hey he can't
kick you know okay well let's like let's
go through it okay he can't the Falcons
that their defense in the NFC
Championship game they're allowed to
stop the Falcons I checked the rule book
they were allowed to stop the Falcons
that day you know he can't recover the
onside kick when he gives his team an
11-point lead on the road an NFC
championship game in the fourth quarter
against one of the greatest defenses
we've ever seen so all those have to be
taken into account too you know it's not
just about him there's other guys that
have messed up just like this year what
happened to Green Bay in the Aaron
Rodgers well he was really close to
making magic at the end of the Rams game
when he was getting on fire they were
they fumbled the kick return we've
talked about the Patriots game it was
like here he is he's in the zone he's
starting to take over the game Aaron
Jones fumbles oh okay he's making some
amazing plays up in Seattle they're not
gonna go forward on fourth and one
they're gonna punch it oh they don't get
the ball back the game's over so he had
three opportunities this year where
there could have been defining moments
that he talked about that could have
changed their season and they weren't
presented to him to actually do it and
save the team because other people
messed it up big cat was on with me at
some point within the past couple of
weeks on a Friday and he said it takes
him an hour to wake up into the show
that Aaron Rodgers has this thing where
it takes like an hour for him or longer
to wake up yes during a game it doesn't
well yep how about wake up from the
beginning of it because I think it's
always a it's a bit of crap offense
you've heard that so he's always going
to all right how do I got a figure at
this out today to make it happen
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports